j'ai un cadeau pour vous on attend
d'avoir un magicien hors pair c'est bien
c'est gus hors pair rien dire mais vous
au repaire ségus offert pour vous un
tour de magie dont qui lui a été inspiré
par l'amour alors gugusses si vous
pensez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà
avec elle
la scène est à vous allez avant de
commencer le numéro daniel moi je suis
un grand fan de comédies romantiques et
ce numéro ne m'a été inspiré par un film
qui s'appelle love actually
vous avez vu se félicitait ressembler de
ouf
ah bah merci c'est peu dans le bleu il a
dans les prochaines minutes c'est
vraiment c'est avec daniel que ça se
passe alors je vous demande vraiment de
peut-être nous laisser faire le numéro
sans même si qu'on sorte la journée pour
deux secondes à préparer j'arrive tout
de suite c'est toujours ce qu'on me dit
[Musique]
oui ça oui oui j'ai une bonne vue bien
oui oui
trop fort
c'est quoi une carte haute ah non non
non deux de pique
[Musique]
non non non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bah oui
alors
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous autorisez allez un petit peu plus
loin alors avec têtu prouver même
l'emmener chez vous d'un petit cadeau
pour vous danielle hawey vous pouvez
l'être déchiré en deux s'il vous plaît
prenez n'importe quel sens de manière
dramatique et théâtrale si c'est
possible c'est pas mal 208 en plein de
petits morceaux de piano
est-ce que vous souvenez de l'ambiance
cas dans les rues de londres au moment
de cette déclaration d'amour dans love
actually
cet organisme est très romantique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]